[Música]
você
agora manda
mais corto corto e não corte o povo quer
que eu corte fica falando corta esse
cabelo corta não linda só cortar esse
cabelo não corto deixa só o cabelo
crescer a senhora aqui tá precisando
calva calva eu não vou ficar tirando o
meu que é só se for se eu tirar também
eu dou PR
Ela já tem é porque a mulher faz piada
de Calvo que não tem mulher calva não
mas tem mulher calva não tem não e é
muita E como tem eu faço pegar um bocado
de calvinha ai não olha aqui não que eu
não tenho cabelo eu digo coisa linda ISO
não tem nada a ver isso não tem nada a
ver e tal e é
sal tô nem vendo para ser
careca Isso é fato aia
rapaz